compte 13 des villes les plus polluées
du monde même Mumbai ville côtière est
enveloppée d'un voile de pollution
se dégrade prévienne les environnements
à
forte croissance démographique
dépendante au charbon boum de la
construction les causes sont multiples
et les victimes nombreuses la pollution
atmosphérique fait plus d'un million de
morts par année en Inde
réduire la pollution au carbone c'est le
pari de cette entreprise émergente qui a
vu le jour en 2016 les déchets
industriels et certaines émissions de
CO2 sont récupérés stérilisés et réduit
en fines poudre qui sert ensuite à
fabriquer des tuiles
compte éventuellement élargir sa gamme
de produits et aider à construire un
million de résidences au bilan carbone
négatif d'ici 2030 même si le marché
demeure timide pour le moment
[Musique]
le fondateur de carbone kraft veut
croire que l'Inde habitué à recycler et
réutiliser les matériaux par nécessité
depuis longtemps adoptera ses produits
en Inde le recyclage est un vaste marché
de 50 milliards de dollars annuellement
une industrie désorgan isée et
fragmentée on compte plus de 25000
entreprises allant des grands
conglomérats ou simple travailleur des
bidons villes de Mumbai
tout commence ici une petite montagne de
déchets de plastique comme on en trouve
un peu partout dans le bidonville de
d'aravi
un premier tri est ensuite fait dans de
petits commerces improvisés les gros
déchets sont fendus à la machette pour
être revendu
dans une usine suffoquante et enfumée le
plastique est ensuite fondu le produit
qui en ressort ressemble à du sable
[Musique]
les employés de cet atelier rudimentaire
utilisent les grains de plastique
réutilisées pour fabriquer des jouets
pour enfants et des pinces pour les
cheveux
le plastique ne disparaîtra pas dit le
propriétaire c'est bien qu'on le
réutilise à notre façon comme plusieurs
autres petits commerçants il s'est lancé
en affaires dans ce domaine il y a
quelques années quand il a vu l'occasion
de faire des profits si chaque petit
initiative doit être salué c'est loin
d'être suffisant rappel cet
environnementaliste
économique l'Inde doit apprendre à
concilier protection de l'environnement
et croissance rapide il suffit Leblanc
Radio-Canada Mumbai